24 faut-il y voir une forme de
provocation à minima de défis Ukraine a
annoncé je vous lisais le départ d'un
porte-conteneur depuis au dessin via une
nouvelle route maritime une manière donc
de répondre au blocus russe en mer Noire
Moscou de son côté a menacé de couler de
tel navire depuis la fin de l'école sur
l'exportation des céréales pour en
savoir plus on va tout de suite
retrouver notre correspondante en
Ukraine Emmanuel Chaze bonjour Emmanuel
premier départ de cargo je le disais et
ce malgré les menaces russes
bonjour Antoine et bien oui
effectivement premier départ d'un cargo
du port d'Odessa en passant par un
corridor temporaire voulu et ouvert par
le crâne depuis une semaine le crâne
avait affirmé vouloir ouvrir ce corridor
afin de permettre à certains navires
bloqué certains depuis plus d'un an et
demi bloqué dans ses ports de tout de
même partir avec leur cargaison cette
fois-ci c'est le navire Joseph Schulz
qui bat pavillon à Hong Kong qui a pris
le départ ce matin avec à son bord 30
000 tonnes de cargaisons dont des
céréales donc le crâne qui met en oeuvre
ce qu'elle avait annoncé il y a une
semaine il faut savoir que ce départ de
cargo il s'effectue bien évidemment avec
l'accord du capitaine de ce de ce navire
et comme vous l'avez dit malgré les
menaces russes on sait qu'hier la Russie
a intercepté à un navire qui se rendait
à Odessa un navire également de
cargaison et que le pays menaces de
considérer comme une cible potentielle
tout navire en provenance ou en partance
des ports
Ukrainiens à un moment où la Russie
cible également ses ports ukrainien le
la nuit dernière la défense
ukrainienne a affirmé avoir abattu 13
drones qui ce qui était en qui ce visait
les ports Ukrainiens de réni et de
Ismail dans le sud du pays des frappes
des bombardements russes au cours de
cette attaque ont endommagé des dépôts
de céréales donc les attaques russes qui
continuent par les airs et la défiance
ukrainienne avec ce départ d'un cargo ce
matin Emmanuel dans le même temps la
contre-offensive ukrainienne se poursuit
sur le front les autorités de Ukraine et
non d'ailleurs annoncé la reprise d'un
village sur le front sud c'est fois il
s'appelle orageaini quelle est
l'importance de cette annonce Emmanuel
oui tout à fait la reprise d'un village